you've auditioned we never talked about
this you're such a funny performer
you've auditioned for starting out live
a couple of times and I can't imagine
you you'd be so great on that show
you've done impressions for them and
that's something I don't see you doing
do you do an unimpressed for SNL yes it
depends on audition you want to probably
just stick to the good like which what
like what are your impressions like
what's what's a bad impression the bad
one is my George Bush yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they seem to like that one pretty good
you do a Tracy Morgan impression yeah
hey the party is twice it for soon the
house dangle I like your hair
touch my belly
you also do an impression of a turtle
I'm told I don't know anything about
this impression you do an impression of
a turtle and I'm told you you need help
getting into turtle character if you
guys have some lettuce yes I taught was
told I don't know what I didn't know
anything they just said you can do this
impression if I have some lettuce ready
what do you want me to do you guys are
luring the turtle to lettuce okay
so so so what honey just give her some
give the turtle some lettuce give her
some lettuce all right here we go
[Applause]
oh pretty good scam you got to get free
lettuce ah yeah hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos